désolé quasi marcher sous le viaduc voler
la - façade Nicole OE ii cette couverture
luca elle fait des films sur la panthère mais des
films également sur le Wakanda verront -
Chavez les français nous demandons la
réponse vous savez l'argent assis sur ce trône
pour des virgules les blessures ont été en hausse  depuis sa
création, c'est le secret le mieux gardé
au monde parce qu'ils ont quelque chose
que le monde veut,
ils ont cette ressource naturelle qui
prospère en quelque sorte grâce à leur
technologie d'extraction, c'est très recherché par
quiconque a déjà été en contact avec
elle panthère noire  demandé de surveiller
une nation entière et également de considérer
la place de cette nation et comment elle affecte le
reste du monde pour voir un
pays africain avec des rois, des reines et des
guerriers, c'est tellement inspirant que c'est juste un
monde incroyable à occuper